each of you see as the main issues with
either quantizing gravity or gravitizing
the quantum air coins then calls it
geometrizing the quantum starting with
Stefan Professor Stefan Alexander please
um
well there are it depends on the
perspective you take
um
you know general relativity
Einstein field goal relativity is based
on
um the principle of
background dependence or diffiomorphism
and variants coordinate labels are
fictitious I mean they are not physical
right you can always Define physics in a
completely different coordinate system
and the physics should be the same and
quantum mechanics you know in its
formulation at least
um in Quantum field Theory the structure
of quantum fuel theory for example if
you talk about you know unifying quantum
mechanics with special relativity
um you still are doing physics in some
given frame and you know making sort of
combining there's a tension now right
because how do you define quantum
mechanics in a background independent
way there have been attempts to do that
I'm happy to talk about those attempts
and you know they've seen some success
but um there's also
um problems
um the main problem of course for me as
a
just a physicist that pays a lot of
attention to observations is that
um it's difficult to explain
um
so sometimes some of these theories are
said to be um unphysical and I can get
back to that about what that means what
I'm physical means
um they're fraught with certain
conceptual and Technical problems these
background independent formulations of
quantum gravity and then you have things
like string theory which
is a successful
perturbative way of defining
of combining some aspects of general
relativity with quantum mechanics
um but again I have worked on string
theory I've worked on string theory
mainly at the level of string
phenomenology or string cosmology and
you know it provides a good toolbox but
also
String Theory itself has its own
um issues and unresolved problems and
that's why it's still an active field of
research so that's my little summary
about um why quantum gravity is so hard
to so we we currently don't have a
consensus in terms of you know
physicists we don't have a consensus
about a theory of quantum gravity so if
we don't have a consensus then we don't
really have a theory of quantum Revenue
actually uh Professor Alexander I agree
with every every syllable you've added
uh it makes a lot of sense yes
think of it possibly possibly just to
add a little
maybe from ignorance or lack of
knowledge uh uh deep within physical
Theory but what if it's not just about
quantizing the gravitational field or
geometrizing the quantum as Dr Weinstein
Eric Weinstein says what if it's about
something else as well what if there is
a Super Force a force of unification
that somehow combines all four forces
given that the force of gravity is
acceptable as a force and not just the
space-time curvature and so forth
and this Super Force could be
for example Isaac Newton let's go back
to
way before all right circus 1693 A.D
thank goodness for that uh
1693 he writes a letter to one of his
buddies Richard bought I think Sir
Richard Bentley he says What If gravity
is the result of an agent
big a capital A that acts
constantly
throughout the Universe in accordance to
given laws of nature
and my question is what if this agent
Kapolei is the Super Force now
which by by the way I think Quantum
balance should be called ashtaker bounds
in the in the lqg in Loop quantum
gravity
um
and I think it he's got something and we
have to discuss this this whole idea of
the ashtakar bonds the quantum balance
because there may be some sort of Super
Force super density resulting in a super
bang I know I know
you see what happens when you agree to a
conversation with uh so let me interject
if you don't mind I want to frame this
conversation I know that I've said this
to both of you Stefan Alexander is a
professor of theoretical physics at
Brown University and holds many
accolades and I'll list those in the
actual intro itself and Salvatore Pius
is an engineer working at the Navy us
space four slash I know that you can't
say exactly what your position is but
the point is that rarely to those in the
academic circles listen to those who are
outside of it especially when those who
are on the outside feel like they have
some Grand idea because you generally
get pitch them left right and Center
when you're an academic and so it's
difficult to separate the wheat from the
chef with Stefan what I like about you
is that you take your cues from physics
from Jazz which is that if someone
throws you an idea you play with it and
you throw back to the person you
mentioned that this is how you work with
your graduate students so this is
supposed to be or this is this whole
conversation is an example of what would
ordinarily happen behind closed doors
being brought to the public and so
hopefully it's something that
researchers
can aspire to so that's what frames this
conversation this
so This respect that seldom shown in
compassion work between let's say
Academia and those who are outside when
they have large ideas Grand ideas Grand
unification
right so on that note on that note so
let me um ask
um let me respond to Sal uh sure that's
great so first of all Sal uh please call
me Stefan uh thank you sir appreciate it
yeah and um
so so I'm gonna push back a little bit
I'm gonna say well you you push I'm
gonna push back and agree with you the
first thing I'm going to agree with is
that your idea of let's say the Super
Force meaning that UNIF that
quantization of gravity
can only happen with a unification
scheme where basically there's some
Force let's call it your Super Force or
some Force or
something that underlies all
the force of gravity right and the
forces that quantum mechanics actually
you know um unifies itself so Quantum
field theory was an example of um a way
of unifying the three interactions the
three um you know the weak interaction
the strong interaction and the
electromagnetic interaction at least I
mean Quantum field theory is a language
at least okay um you know Quantum fuel
Theory engage invariance right is a
language right or the technology the
conceptual mathematical technology that
underlies those three forces right
um
the Super Force you know this
unification of gravity with these other
three forces
this was actually the program of string
theory right string theory and it's it's
parent you know when people some people
call I think I find this it's parent
Theory actually very interesting Matrix
Theory right the idea that you know what
even underline what underlines the
overarching framework that
um that string theory
comes from is a matrix
um quantum mechanics so now I think what
is interesting about what you're saying
is that
there's one thing to say that forces
including gravity are Unified
but your perspective what I'm hearing
your perspective is that you're calling
that unification a Super Force and
therefore I'm gonna ask you what is that
Force you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy